الدفاع الروسيه سارقه شويجو ان العمليه
العسكريه في باخمت مستمره وخلال اجتماعه
مع قياده القوات المسلحه اعلن شويغو عن
مقتل اكثر من احد عشر الف عسكريين من
القوات الاوكرانيه خلال شهر فبراير الماضي
دعم دولي نيتو لنظام الاوكراني لا يحقق
نجاحا للقوات الاوكرانيه في ساحه المعركه
نلاحظ ارتفاعا كبيرا في خسائر افرادها في
فبراير فقط ارتفعت نسبه الخسائر في صفوف
الجنود الاوكرانيين بمقدار 40% مقارنه مع
يناير وتجاوزت احد عشر الف عسكري عمليه
تحرير مدينه باخموت مستمره فهي مركز دفاع
اوكراني مهم في دومباس والسيطره عليها
ستسمح لقواتنا بشن هجوم في عمق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه
ومن جهه اقاله الكرملين ان العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا تحقق اهدافها وانه
لا شروط مسبقه على انتقال الوضع في
اوكرانيا الى مسار سلمي واتهم الكرملين
واشنطن بعدم الرغبه في انهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وبذل قصار جهدها لمواصلتها
بالموقف الصيني من الحرب لافتا الى ان
روسيا تو الاهتماما كبيرا لموقف الصين
ازاء الوضع في اوكرانيا
ومعنا الان من مراسل للجزيره حسان مسعود
ومن موسكو مراسلتنا رانيا دريدي رانيا
وحسان اهلا بكما في المنتصف ابدا معك حسان
لتخبرنا عما يجري تحديدا في
باخموت ومحيطها لان التصريحات بالامس كانت
متضاربه كيف يمكن وصف الوضع من الجانب
الاوكراني
نعم ليلى وللاجابه على التساؤلات من
الجانب الاوكراني توجهنا الى هنا الى
دينابرو للقاء المتحدث باسم قياده القوات
الاوكرانيه في الشرق الاوكراني للحديث
بشكل واضح عن الواقع على الارض في باخمت
وقبل قليل انهينا لقاء خاصا تحدث فيه
للجزيره عن عدد من نقاط شرح فيها هذا
الواقع الواقع على الارض طبعا وفقا
للروايه الاوكرانيه كان يتحدث عن ان
القوات الروسيه تريد هذا الاسبوع ان تسيطر
على بخموت وواضح من بدايه هذا الاسبوع
انها تقوم بهجمات كبيره باتجاه المواقع
الاوكرانيه عبر وحدات خاصه وعبر قوات
فاجنر وعبر كذلك وحدات من المظليه
وتؤازرها
مدافع ووحدات المدفعيه لكنها تتمكن كما لم
تتمكن خلال ثمان اشهر
السابقه وقال ان القرار الواضح من القياده
في اوكرانيا او بعد اجتماع الرئيس
الاوكراني مع قياده الجيش هو مواصله
القتال في باخموت والصمود في المواقع
الاوكرانيه في باخمت واكد على ان الوضع هو
صعب والقوات الروسيه تريد ان تحسم الامر
في ضخمه لكن القوات الاوكرانيه
تفشل كل الهجمات التي تقوم بها القوات
الروسيه باتجاه مدينه باخموت وما زالت في
مواقعها لم تتراجع عن مواقعها وفقه قوله
وفق ما اكد لي الجزيره قبل دقائق هذا واكد
كذلك المتحدث باسم قياده القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في
الشرقي شريفاتي ان لدى القياده الاوكرانيه
خطط اثبتت نجاحها في
تعبيره وان هذه القياده قامت بزياره
باخموت ولديها خطط لا تستطيع ان تطلع
عليها الراي العام لكنه اكد على ان لا
خيار حتى هذه اللحظه لا حديث من الجانب
الاوكراني عن انسحاب وقال ان الحاله
الوحيده التي يمكن ان يحدث فيها انسحاب من
اي منطقه سواء كانت باخمت او غيرها هو ان
تكون القوات الاوكرانيه في خطر وان تاتي
القرارات من القياده العليا بالانسحاب
لكنها ليست الحاله في هذه اللحظه في باخمت
وفق قوله قال ايضا ان القوات الاوكرانيه
مازالت تتصدى بكل ايضا امكاناتها لهذه
الهجمات وهي مستعده للقيام بهجوم مضاد في
اي وقت ايضا وفق الخطط التي وضعتها هذا هو
المشهد بشكل ربما ملخص وفق ما قاله
باسم قياده عمليات الشرق وهو الذي عاده ما
يدلي هذه التصريحات حول الواقع في ضخمه
لكن من الواضح انه كما كنا نراقب هناك في
الميدان بالقرب من بخ في الجهه الغربيه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه كانت تقوم بضربات
صاروخيه ومدفعيه وفي ذات الوقت كنا نتابع
التصريحات الرسميه والواقع على الارض يشير
الى تصاعد حده الضربات المدفعيه من الجانب
الروسي باتجاه مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه
وهو ما اكده ايضا المتحدث باسم قياده
عمليات الشرق في الجيش الاوكراني على
العموم سنتابع لقائك مع المتحدث باسم
القوات الاوكرانيه التي وردت فيه نقاط
مهمه للغايه ولعله ايضا الشار الى ان
الحديث عن انقسام بين
الجهه السياسيه والعسكريه في روسيا دعايه
غربيه والى جانب نقاط اخرى اشكرك حسان على
هذه المعلومات سانتقل الان الى رانيا
وايضا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صدر عنها عدد
من التصريحات من بينها تدمير مخازن
للذخيره في دنياتك وايضا اسقاط مقاتله
سخوي 24 تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه في دنيا
هل لديك المزيد من التفاصيل
نعم يعني ليلى هذا ياتي في اطار يعني
المعطيات الرسميه اليوميه لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه التي تتحدث فيها عما تم تحقيقه من
انجازات بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه خلال اليوم
الماضي وهنا اود الاشاره الى ان حصيله
خزائر القوات المسلحه الروسيه او عفوا
الاوكرانيه خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه قد بلغت نحو 300 عسكري اوكراني
الحديث يدور عن خسائر كبيره تتكبثها
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه على عده محاور
اهمها محور كوب محور كراسي نيمار
محور محور دانياسك الجنوبي وايضا محور
ولكن
الاهم من ذلك حاليا ما يجري حاليا في ضخم
حيث ان السلطات المحليه في دنيس الصباح
اليوم اكلت ان نصف مساحه هذه المدينه باتت
تحت سيطره القوات المسلحه
الروسيه وهنا اود الاشاره الى تصريحات
وزير الدفاع الروسي سر جيجو الذي اكد ان
على
بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني هي محور دفاعي
مهم في دامباس وان يعني
السيطره على هذه المدينه من قبل القوات
المسلحه الروسيه سيسمح للقوات الروسيه
بالتقدم وشنه هجمات في العمق عمق خطوط
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ايضا هناك لابد من
الاشاره الى ان وزير الدفاع الروسي تحدث
كثيرا فيما يتعلق باستمرار الدول الغربيه
بتزويد الجانب الاوكراني بالاسلحه اشاره
الى ان هذه الخطوه لا تسمح للقوات
الاوكرانيه بتحقيق نجاحات بل على العكس
حسب تعبيره خسائر القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في ازدياد تحدث عن ان هذه
الخسائر قد ارتفعت بنسبه 40% وذلك فقط
خلال شهر فبراير الماضي مقارنه مع شهر
يناير الماضي خلال شهر فبراير وحده ليله
تكبدت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه خسائر
تجاوزت احد عشر الف عسكري اوكرانيا هذا من
جهه من اخرى من جانبه الكريملين ايضا
تناول هذه الجزئيه واشار الى ان كل ذلك
ياتي في اطار محاولات الولايات المتحده
لاستمرار الصراع لا مؤشرات حسب تعبير
الكريم لاي مفاوضات مستقبليه او اي تسويه
مستقبليه سلميه للازمه الاوكرانيه وعليه
فان روسيا مستمره في عمليه العسكريه وهي
مستمره وتعمل على تحقيق الاهداف التي
وضعتها امامها القياده المسلحه الروسيه
وان كل ما يقوم تقوم فيه الولايات المتحده
حاليا هو محاولات
لتمديد امد هذا الصراع لاكبر قدر ممكن هي
لا تريد انهاء هذا الحرب عليه تستمر
بتزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح اشكرك رانيا
جزيلا من